hier sa réputation n'est plus à faire
on sait qu'il ya de bons moments dans ce
spectacle est aussi le risque de faire
du théâtre filmé un cru mais là c'est
pas du tout le cas
c'est pas du tout là parce que durée et
son collaborateur ont fait un énorme
travail de mise en scène
alors la mise en scène la mise en scène
ne cessait de créer des extérieurs par
exemple wi2wi entre autres mais la mise
en scène c'est aussi 200 anachronisme
lire monsieur jourdain monde pas dans
son cabriolet
il a il conduit à conserver l'unité de
temps aya dire que ça se déroule sur 24
heures comme dans la pièce mais il a il
a agrémenté les indications de mise en
scène de théâtre avec les moyens dont
dispose et le théâtre à l'époque pour le
cinéma c'est à dire par exemple que au
début du
du film quand les maîtres de musique et
de balais arrive pour arnaquer ce gros
montjoire fait parce que c'est bien le
salon il s'agit et c'est bien là dessus
de kodjo a insisté parce qu'aujourd'hui
il ya des musiciens qui arnaquent des
roues bourgeois qui leur prennent de 30
bâton pour faire un album il par exemple
il rentre la première chose qu'ils font
c'est de rentrer dans la cuisine et de
se jeter sur quelques brioches qui
traîne ça c'est pas indiqué dans me dire
ouais mais quand on nettoie les sens ça
n'est pas en contradiction et qui
concernent la vie elle est à bord avec
le décor abstrait au contraire une
espèce de 2,2 de souci presque
ethnologique
bien qu'il s'en défende d'affaires de
kodjo qui fait que ce molière qui est un
peu figé dans nos esprits parce qu'on
n'en connaît que la version du petit
bordas qu'on nous donne dans les lycées
prend une dimension de 2,2 de vie et
surtout de lait devient ce que je ne
voterai pas exactement tout en gardant
les caractéristiques de la sienne or à
ce propos bon c'est très lourd le
dispositif vestimentaire de l'époque et
on doit souffrir devant les caméras
est-ce que tu as souffert moi je peux
pas trop souffert parce qu'en plus je
suis habituée aux corsetage et aux
frises est oui mais pour parler
notamment par exemple des costumes le
lien il ya eu un excès un fantastique
travail justement de recherche
2 de la part des gens qui ont fait des
costumes le maquillage le décor qu'est
ce qui est étonnant que le decs le texte
bon c'est le texte père veilleux qu'on
connaît mais c'est pas si facile à dire
je peux enfin je crois que la pose de
molière j'ai pas si elle est d'accord
c'est je crois que ce qui est presque de
plus difficile à dire
on peut penser comme ça à première
lecture que c'est assez parlant fait si
redoutable et c'est une grande
difficulté effectivement oui surtout à
l'écran il manie la langue
imany sa prose comme l'est de manille
delà le vert c'est à dire qu'il ya une
dynamique qu'il impose par les mots par
les césures ton doit absolument risma
respect règne
oui c'est ça une musicalité dans la
langue qu'on doit respecter et on croit
en lisant le bourgeois qui tue qui et en
prose on se dit dieu merci à pas les
yamada s'avère efficace en la même
suggestion problème si c'était une
première
lambert
[Musique]